[Música]
aquí inicia un capítulo especial de
áfrica siete días este es un magazine
informativo 100% dedicado al continente
africano
en esta oportunidad le presentamos el
primero de nuestros dos programas
especiales dedicados a la conmemoración
de las independencias que tuvieron lugar
en el continente africano en agosto de
1960 un año que marcó la historia del
continente especialmente para los países
francófonos de áfrica occidental veamos
entonces en nuestra pantalla cuáles son
los 8 países que están conmemorando los
60 años de su independencia en este mes
de agosto estos son benín y níger
burkina faso costa de marfil chad congo
brazzaville república centroafricana y
finalmente gabón en este capítulo
recordaremos la independencia de los
cuatro primeros de ellos que justamente
son benin níger burkina faso y costa de
marfil
y es que el primero de los ocho países
de alcanzar su soberanía fue la
república popular de venir el primero de
agosto de 1960 una nación conocida
anteriormente como dahomey veamos la
historia
[Música]
el primero de agosto de 1960 benin aún
se llamaba dahomey tras la firma del
acuerdo que les garantizaba la total
independencia de francia tras más de
seis décadas de colonia el primer
ministro yves maga se preparaba para dar
un histórico discurso
pueblo dado mella no proclamó
solemnemente la independencia de dahomey
este lunes primero de agosto de 1960
minutos son hambre 2 en presencia de
representantes de la república francesa
y de toda la población la població sin
embargo las promesas de soberanía se
quedaron algo cortas y la sociedad
beninesa no goza de una total
emancipación francia siempre trata de
seguir teniendo cierta influencia en sus
antiguas colonias
así que de la dominación las relaciones
se transforman en influencia y en un
intercambio más o menos desigual
su único vestigio de la colonia es la
moneda de benin el cdc ha siglas que
hasta el 2019 significaban colonia
francesa de áfrica eso cambio en
diciembre cuando los 8 países de la
unión monetaria de áfrica occidental
decidieron adoptar el eco una divisa
común cuyo valor seguirá dependiendo del
euro y que aún no está en circulación el
gobierno francés ha dado pasos en los
últimos años para desligarse de su
pasado colonialista
ellos la promesa de devolver varios
artefactos robados de bening que aún
permanecen en museos o colecciones
privadas en francia mientras eso sucede
el país africano celebro sus seis
décadas de independencia oficial con una
pequeña ceremonia liderada por el
presidente beninés pachista long y con
medidas de bioseguridad por la pandemia
de kobe 19
pues aquí en france 24 hablamos
previamente concepto abandonó el gestor
cultural nacido justamente en berlín que
nos dio su opinión acerca de cómo han
vivido esos 60 años las naciones
francófonos de áfrica occidental en los
habló desde bogotá colombia
si hablo de benin de costa de marfil de
níger de burkina faso yo diría que es un
poco la misma cosa
punto político primero creo que
realmente no podemos hablar de
independencia cuando un país no tiene la
soberanía cuando un presidente electo en
sus países de áfrica francófona tiene
que ir primero a francia para recibir
órdenes
no se puede hablar de soberanía cuando
se mata sistemáticamente o se anula se
cancela el poder del presidente que
quiere realmente hacer reformas y tomar
realmente verdadero poder podemos hablar
de thomas sankara podemos hablar de
lumumba podemos hablar también de la
bomba que sea frente finalmente al
ejército francés hace unos años atrás
no se puede hablar de su venida también
económica cuando
el costa de marfil es el primer
productor mundial de cacao pero que
vende toda su producción a los países
europeos no se puede hablar tampoco de
soberanía cuando la moneda que circula
en áfrica del oeste sigue siendo
fabricada en francia para el futuro yo
creo que lo bueno sería que africano
sigue con las ideas
de progreso occidental sino encontrarse
reventarse
como formalmente una persona que se
encuentra en un momento de crisis y que
tiene que mirarse a los ojos mirarse al
espejo para ver sus debilidades ver sus
fortalezas para seguir avanzando con
fuerza con resiliencia pues después de
benin continuamos este especial de
áfrica siete días hablando de níger este
país proclamó su independencia el 3 de
agosto de 1860 después de varias décadas
de resistencia veamos
frente al palacio de niamey se reunieron
funcionarios invitados a celebrar la
independencia de níger en medio de las
fiestas del 3 de agosto de 1960 se
realizó una carrera de caballos y
camellos mieres un país rural cuya
economía se basa en la ganadería y la
agricultura entre los objetivos del
nuevo gobierno está desarrollar las
exportaciones del país pero también
modernizar la mentalidad de la sociedad
nigerina para liberarse gradualmente de
la tutela francesa no se trata de abolir
los escalones de mando europeo por el
momento la africanización será gradual
en níger como ha visto hay hombres de
todos los colores
los primeros europeos en entrar en la
región fueron los británicos a
principios del siglo 19 con el objetivo
de encontrar nuevas materias primas
alrededor de 1890 los franceses llegaron
al lago chad cerca del cual se
encontraba el imperio kahneman borno
para apoderarse de este territorio
sometieron al sultán rapa
la resistencia actuar en la región en
níger fue integrado al territorio
colonial que para entonces se llamaba
áfrica occidental francesa aof niamey se
convirtió en la capital de esta colonia
hasta entonces dominada por los pueblos
hausa que vivían ancestralmente en la
región en 1958 pasó a formar parte de la
comunidad francesa creada por el general
charles de gaulle a pesar de la
resistencia del líder independentista de
boubacar y quien fomentó un golpe de
están pero su iniciativa fue frustrada y
tuvo que exiliarse más tarde el líder
hammam y diory también tuvo que negociar
con los jefes de los pueblos locales
con la independencia se ofrecerán
puestos gerenciales a las jefaturas es
en la tradición nigerina pero los abusos
deben combatirse para que el jefe se
convierta en un funcionario moderno
[Música]
en noviembre de 1960 hamani diori fue
elegido presidente de la republica por
la asamblea nacional del país integrada
únicamente por el partido popular cinco
años después fue víctima de un intento
de asesinato y finalmente fue derrocado
por el ejército del 15 de abril de 1974
[Música]
pues seguimos con este recorrido
especial de áfrica siete días por las
independencias africanas y vamos ahora a
burkina faso porque este país
anteriormente conocido como alto volta
progreso soberanía el 5 de agosto de
1960 la nación cuenta con un sector
agrícola saludable y es un importante
exportador de oro y de algodón
es el 5 de agosto de 1960 los
principales líderes africanos y
franceses se reúnen para asistir a un
momento histórico la independencia de la
república de alto volta el nuevo
presidente de maurice yaméogo planta un
árbol para simbolizar la independencia y
las esperanzas de toda una nación
meyer compatriotas vuelve
[Música]
mis compatriotas el 5 de agosto de 1960
a la medianoche el nombre del derecho
humano natural la libertad la igualdad y
la fraternidad proclamó solemnemente la
independencia de la república de alto
con el mal n penas de la république de
vuelta
década de 1890 tanto francia como gran
bretaña se habían embarcado en una
conquista de áfrica cientos de soldados
entraron en los reinos mussi dejando un
rastro de destrucción detrás de ellos
después de la conquista inicial el
protectorado de uagadugú se convirtió en
parte del áfrica occidental francesa
durante la primera guerra mundial
los combatientes moss y se convirtieron
en una parte integral de los batallones
africanos que luchar por francia en 1919
francia decidió crear el alto volta
francés pero para reforzar su autoridad
el poder colonizador desmanteló el
territorio en varias partes después de
la segunda guerra mundial el país
recuperó su unidad y junto con sus
países vecinos alto volta se unió a la
unión francesa cumpliendo la visión de
charles de gaulle después de la
independencia el presidente yaméogo
prohibió todos los partidos políticos
excepto el suyo seis años más tarde un
movimiento masivo popular lo sacó del
poder en 1983 un golpe militar llevó al
gran comandante tomás es tan cara al
poder
quien cambió el nombre del país de alto
volta a burkina faso que significa
tierra de hombres honestos
y finalizamos este programa especial de
áfrica siete días hablando de costa de
marfil que logró su independencia el 7
de agosto de 1960 el hombre clave en los
años posteriores a la independencia fue
el primer presidente del país félix
hufué buañí veamos la historia
costa de marfil fue colonia francesa
desde 1803 hasta el 7 de agosto de 1960
durante los primeros años de este
período se formaron movimientos de
resistencia contra los colonos en
particular liderado por samory touré de
1907 dos nuevas protestas emanan esta
vez por parte de los propietarios
locales de las plantaciones de café y
cacao quienes aseguraban ser víctimas de
discriminación en comparación con los
propietarios europeos su líder se
llamaba feliz nuevo año un hombre clave
de las décadas recientes en 1944 fundó
el sindicato de plantadores americanos
parís consideraba carismático y por
tanto peligroso pero poco a poco se fue
acercando a francia e incluso se
convirtió en ministro del gobierno
francés en 1956 domingo en el momento de
la independencia cuatro años después
decidió mantener relaciones línea
estrechas con parís es la época de la
guerra fría y él claramente eligió su
posición se le atribuye la invención del
término frágil que inicialmente según él
subrayaba los estrechos vínculos de mis
lados
ciudades con el tiempo el significado de
este término ha evolucionado ahora más
bien designa las relaciones opacas y
manzanas que pueden existir entre parís
y ciertas élites africanas en las
antiguas colonias francesas actual y con
la independencia que estableció un
régimen de partido único durante tres
décadas y el desarrollo económico fue
real pero luego se vio frenado por la
caída del precio del café y el cacao en
el mercado mundial
felix hufue buañi lidera el país con
firmeza y no fue hasta 1990 que
estableció un sistema multipartidista
que fue libio
tres años después ha de pagar desde su
muerte o sea de marfil ha vivido varios
momentos de gran tensión incluida en el
crisis poselectoral de 2010 y 2011 que
dejó más de 3.000 muertos hoy el
crecimiento económico ha vuelto pero el
clima político no está del todo calmado
así finalizamos este capítulo especial
de áfrica siete días pero les recordamos
que la próxima semana tendremos las
otras 4 independencias que tuvieron
lugar en el continente durante el mes de
agosto de 1960 así finalizamos ustedes
continúen con más en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom nos vemos más adelante
[Música]